[Music]
existence of the Super Bowl suggests
that there are lesser Bowls it's three
hours of the best adverts of the year
occasionally cut up with the odd bit of
sport maybe they win a large bowl for
competing in it each team has exactly
one million players the most baffling
thing is that they seem to actively like
getting hurt it's like watching the
matrix but in public there's a person
that comes on to kick the ball it
doesn't do anything else and yet gets
paid millions of dollars all I want to
know how I get that job
it looks like the TVs have an effect
because it's all covered in like images
and animated things they normally do
some kind of extremely choreographed
mishap you know where their clothes fall
off best bit worth staying in the sport
doesn't it I don't remember who won the
Super Bowl other than I remember that
Beyonce won the Super Bowl
that's fabulous absolutely brilliant
nobody kind of cornered British builders
did that sort of thing I have no idea
what you said I have no idea what it's
all about and I want to see more if it
actually makes me want to watch American
football which I never have done
[Music]